there's a lot of stuff and Wonderwoman
that's different not just from the
previous DC EU films but for most
superhero movies in general that came
before it as a result it will likely
have a lasting effect on the DC EU
opening doors with regards to world
building and narrative Man of Steel was
an extremely dark and bloody take on a
traditionally upbeat character to the
chagrin of fans and critics Batman vs
Superman took that even further
depicting two heroes who are
traditionally friends as bitterly
opposed for most of the movie Suicide
Squad featured super-powered criminals
forced in the service by the government
so obviously it wasn't sunshine and
rainbows either but Wonder Woman tells a
different story
it's certainly violence it is a war
movie after all but it depicts its title
hero as a symbol of Hope when she's
first revealed in costumes stepping out
into no-man's land in the midst of the
great war the point is not that she's
there to destroy she's there to save
everyone instead in a world where
Superman snaps of villains neck and
Batman brands criminals so they'll be
killed in prison
Wonder Woman offers a refreshing return
to the basic concept of a superhero
moving away from the idea that
traditional heroism has lost its place
it's about what you believe
where Superman is an alien and Batman is
a billionaire with a lot of tech Wonder
Woman is a demigod with magical powers
who grew up in an idyllic Island with
immortal women her movie embraces
fantasy elements to a degree that the
DCE you really hadn't before it may not
be the first DC movie to feature magic
suicide squads villain after all is
literally named The Enchantress but
Diana's origin takes it to another level
this is a movie that starts out in a
purely fantasy setting before
introducing the real world even the MCU
presents Asgard as more of a sci-fi
realm in another dimension that merely
inspired earth mythology Wonder Woman
however doesn't hedge its bets like that
Diana grows up in a place it's like an
all-female version of Lord of the Rings
that doesn't just shape her abilities
it also effects her outlook her reaction
to learning about the horrors of World
War 1 is to go on a quest to defeat a
mad god she's a superhero to be sure but
she is also a fantasy character and that
blend is carried off perfectly bringing
her into a world that also features
science-based heroes like cyborg and the
flash creates endless possibilities for
future stories in this universe in
actual real world history Wonder Woman's
first comic book appearance was in 1941
however because comics continuity is
constantly revised to keep everyone
young the version of Wonder Woman in the
current comics only left the mascara
roughly ten years ago the movie takes a
different path as this Diana leaves
during World War one and goes on to live
in the outside world for about a hundred
years as far as we know Wonder Woman was
the first superhero in this version of
Earth that raises the question if she's
been around for a century who else might
have shown up along the way there's a
whole roster of DC Comics characters
from the 1930s and 1940s and with Wonder
Woman setting the precedent it's
possible some of them might have existed
even earlier in the DC EU while it's
unclear if the movies will ever deal
with much of that the precedent has been
set in a 100 year history of superheroes
is rich with possibilities
superheroes tend to be monogamous and
mate for life especially in movies in
that vein Steve Trevor plays a key role
in Wonder Woman's origin stories so it's
no surprise he's a big part of the movie
is played by Chris Pine however since
the film is set a century in the past
there was never a chance for the two to
live happily ever after since she's
immortal and he isn't ultimately the
plot takes it even further with trevor
sacrificing his life to destroy a
Plane full of doctor poisons gasps after
he and Diana kiss for a superhero's
lover to die in a movie is almost
unheard of especially by way of a heroic
sacrifice I wish we had more time
I love you
[Music]
in addition to this narrative departure
director patty Jenkins has said that
Diana will have a different love
interest in the sequel it will
reportedly be set in the 1980s which
means that whoever that person is it
will also likely only last for one movie
depending on how long this goes on
Dianna could become the first superhero
since the 80s and 90s era Batman's have
a different love interest in every movie
Wonder Woman's power goes beyond her
physical and mystical capabilities
within the movies as a character she's
proven to be more powerful than anyone
expected and still has her first movie
the film wasn't just a huge success
financially it was a hit with critics a
feat managed by no previous DC EU movie
in the wake of its release there was a
lively public discussion about how the
creative minds behind the DC EU had
lessons to learn from Wonder Woman I
want her to be everything from me it was
too late to change much about Justice
League which came out only five months
later but going forward it's clear that
it's Wonder Woman not Superman or Batman
who will light the way for the DC
superhero franchise until now Clark and
Bruce have spent too much time fighting
in the dark but it already looks like
that's changing as evidenced by Aquaman
and Shazam which are both brighter and
lighter and tone and color palette than
most of what's come before check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]